[Música]
agrícolas brutos este movimiento nació
como reacción a un importante aumento en
el precio de la electricidad una medida
que afecta principalmente a los
agricultores que utilizan el agua
corriente para hacer funcionar sus
máquinas nuestro observador es un
periodista local cuyo rostro difuminamos
para garantizar su seguridad
Cuando paran estos camiones no los
inspeccionan ni siquiera se acercan a
ellos solo les piden a los conductores
que se hagan a un lado de la carretera a
las personas que tienen una emergencia
las ambulancias y los vehículos de
transporte público les permiten pasar
cuando uno visita esta región Norte se
da cuenta de que la agricultura es la
única fuente de ingresos de esta gente y
ahora con el importante aumento del
precio de la electricidad están
perdiendo su sustento
para exigir que los militares dejen el
poder y continúe la transición política
interrumpida en el golpe de estado del
25 de octubre del 2021 esta protesta ha
evolucionado actualmente la mayoría de
los bloqueos los realizan los comités de
resistencia en apoyo a los agricultores
penalizados por las subidas de
Electricidad los activistas de los
comités de resistencia han llegado
incluso desde cartón y otros estados de
Sudán y se han unido a sus compañeros en
las barricadas 15 km
de hecho estos jóvenes protestan contra
el monopolio del ejército en la vida
pública y política
y porque la mayoría de las grandes
empresas agrícolas que exportan materias
primas al extranjero son propiedad del
ejército sudanés
al Ministerio de economía pero no tuvo
éxito
[Música]
a internet en África hay edificio su
incluso agua potable estas son preguntas
totalmente fuera de contexto sin embargo
los tiktokers africanos que tienen
seguidores internacionales reciben este
tipo de preguntas con mucha regularidad
entre ellos se encuentra
mil suscriptores que ha preferido
responderles con mucho humor
intenté tener un enfoque diferente
me preguntaba si teníamos agua un día
estaba con mis primas en la casa de
nuestro pueblo Y pensé vamos a hacer un
tic Toc algo
la reacción de la gente Fue increíble
[Música]
el comentario más absurdo que recibí fue
tienen iPhone 6 en África Yo decía grabé
estos videos con un teléfono y lo subí a
internet
cuando se trata de algo serio
[Música]
en tik Tok hay muchos videos que
pretenden ser graciosos mostrando
ridículas formas de Cómo enviar agua a
África por eso los tiktokers que luchan
contra los cliché sobre el continente
están encantados de responderlos
África me ofendió mucho este video
también hay gente en todo el mundo
[Música]
especialmente el de África porque eso
demuestra que la gente la que quiero
llegar está recibiendo el mensaje
con la producción del programa puede
hacerlo a través de los puntos de
contacto que aparecen en sus pantallas
esperamos
la próxima semana